okay I think you guys should be able to
hear me what's up how's everybody's day
coming along I'm actually in the middle
of writing the script for death of the
family is probably gonna be another lane
upload these these Batman stories are so
lengthy like that's what kind of drives
me nuts it's like Billy's great being
like 20-something issue crossover events
like Jesus DCE like damn you know but um
but yeah like here's the the issue is
this like with definite family there
really isn't a whole lot of stuff that
we can skip over because it fixes a lot
of continuity issues and Batman's comics
and it explains its continuity and so
you know there's some things that we
just can't leave like you know like we
have to like we have to go over it sort
of it's not as important as other stuff
like there are some things just don't
really matter that much you know but
there are some things that do matter a
lot and so it's really just kind of a
toss-up as to what's more important and
what's not you know but anyway so what's
our buddy doing
how's your roles as Rose today I still
need to read in game yeah what we don't
be doing in game after this like indie
game will probably be next week good
morning yeah after endgame we're
probably just gonna jump straight at Jim
Gordon Batman I'm not really sure when I
do Batman eternal I'm gonna explain the
relationship between the Joker and
Batman in terms of like you know good
and evil and everything but aside from
that it's the audio I to sync guys or is
it just that one dude if there's not a
sync I'll try to see like it fix it or
something but let me know
but uh but videos aren't necessarily 30
minutes all the time they're just
however long they need to be there's no
point in filling there's no point in
making a video and it's 20 minutes full
of extraneous fluff that none of it has
any real value for the sake of making a
20 minute video that's the waste of my
time and it's waste you're all sun-like
I wouldn't just make videos that are
like relevant
and that is thing for you okay cool
what's up Rob just that one dude okay
okay cool
and it was just it was a couple people
and everybody else is fine and their
internet probably sucks so alright um
doing your homework yeah yeah I remember
those days
like I remember getting those like very
big huge like homework assignments and
those things were nuts
but Batman Beyond you know gotta have
yawns funny because it's Batman Beyond
without Terry McGinnis I don't
understand how that works I understand
why DC thought that was a good idea I
got to tell you like I think when
readers sat down and they were like yes
Batman Beyond I can't wait to read about
Tim Drake being mad at me I'm people
were like oh no Terry McGinnis
that's the Batman beyond that I know
like that's that's the issue I think and
it doesn't make any sense to have
somebody beyond teria somebody besides
Terry McGinnis will probably talk about
that at some point again like my like
with the with our DC videos other than
what my goal is to get everybody caught
up like my goal is to get everybody you
know in a position to where they can
basically pick up DC Comics and go from
there is to get my channel current on on
Batman and Superman Wonder Woman we'll
see what they do with her but you know
it may or may not be relevant it really
just kind of depends but right now the
focus is Batman to Superman and then
probably Green Lantern after that so
futures end a future yeah we might do
futures and features and isn't really
relevant like you don't really need
futures end to be quite honest I mean
it's the only relevance of features in
has that it ties into convergence and
that's really about it
let's see what do we think about
Superman vs. Goku - I haven't watched it
yet I watched the first one and I got
enough of an idea I doubt the second
one's really that different from the
first one let's see the best series
start with in what Marvel or DC hi rod
new to the flash TV and do you think the
blue flash is cobalt blue I don't know
that's kind of the weird thing is is
like I don't know it is it's really kind
of hard to figure out because we don't
know what they're gonna be doing the
issue here is it's gonna be the flash
traveling the multiverse and so they
could say like the blue flashes wall
lest they could say that like Wally West
is gonna have the same uniform as a red
raspberry Alex I'm just gonna have the
same you know a few modifications to
differentiate the two of them you know
they could say that Wally West has the
has the the DC version of his outfit you
know in the show like we don't we don't
know I have no idea that's born in truth
dad died just be like throwing out
random speculation if I answer that cost
hey Rob now the Secret Wars is going to
have one extra issue can you speculate
as to what's what's going to be in it oh
I have no idea I mean you know it'd be
different if we were to you know one or
two issues away from that but right now
we're we're halfway done like like
future and perfect just finished so
which had a really good ending by the
way I don't think I saw the feature and
perfect ended really well it was
actually probably one of the coolest
endings out of the entire Secret Wars
event I got to tell you but no I have no
clue I just speculate a little bit um
again we don't really know it'll I think
that it's all gonna hinge on the Phoenix
force to be honest or Reed Richards like
a Reed Richards empowered Phoenix force
maybe I'm not really sure I mean this
here's a thing like it's probably gonna
in in some great big huge battle because
right now we have tano's at the
Deadlands at the walls by the way guys
this video this one's probably only
gonna be about 45 minutes long because I
really need to get to work on this
script for a death of the family like
finish you know finish up the script but
no I mean Thanos is at the at the shield
you know probably gonna ally himself
with the zombies in Ultron probably
overpower and kill a bunch of people in
order to establish his dominance and
like that Reed Richards everybody else
is scattered so it's probably gonna be
Reed Richards you know pulling everybody
together and and basically like
launching an attack I'm assuming anyway
and I have no real idea to be honest
let's see the best x-men story mmm I'm
not sure um they stopped playing for you
uh are you talking my the livestream cuz
I don't know I wanted to tell you on
that one
well do you want walking dead yes um the
best x-men story who probably God loves
man kills that's my opinion anyway I'm
not really a huge fan of the new x-men
stuff because I don't think I think it
all kind of sucks but you know it
depends you know they're the cool so
here's a cool thing about comic book
guys coming books then for those of us
who've been reading it for a long time
we have our favorite stuff you know it's
it's like it's like you know it's like
Call of Duty you know there are people
that started playing Call of Duty when
it first blew up you know when like
seananners hutch you know a movie Swede
trout 91 when all those guys you know
sort of launching their YouTube channels
and they'll say that modern warfare 2 is
the best Call of Duty game of all time
and people who are getting into call
duty right now are picking up like black
ops 3 and that's gonna be the favorite
Call of Duty game of all time because it
was their first you know and it's like
that every you know every time is same
thing with comics you know somebody
walked into a comic book store for the
first time they walk up to to the
counting book you know a guy the river
it is us running the best whether it's
the manager or whoever the employee is
and they say like you know we're you
know I want like I I saw the Avengers
and I'm interested in like Iron Man what
do I read and they say we're check out
superior Iron Man like that's gonna be
their imn because they're gonna be like
wow this is amazing you know and they're
gonna love it and so you know it really
just kind of it depends to be honest I
mean different folks different sorts for
different folks I guess uh you into
Doctor Who now I'm not a big fan of
Doctor Who I've never really watched it
to be honest and I never I never really
intrigue me but then again I said the
same thing about Battlestar Galactica
and then a friend of mine Steve was like
hey man like watch the first three
episodes and if you don't get hooked
that's cool
I'll watch the first three episodes and
Ben watch the rest of the series I've
been binge watched the rest of the
series on Netflix so let's see
you heard about the new just leave
America show in development no I haven't
actually but is it gonna be a live
action or a cartoon I check it out
either way but if I'm reading scott
snyder books do i need to scroll back up
that's a good question
if I read it Scott Snyder books do I
need to read nine of the owls after
quarterly after the court or before city
of the owls um 92 the city of the
islands is kind of all encompassing the
entire arc between the beginning of
night of the owl or beginning of court
of the owls to the end of NIDA yells is
referred to as court of the owls but um
the the reading order goes like this
it's it's core to the owls and then I
guess like in nine of the Owls slash
city of the owls none of the owls
basically picks up like like you should
make even like when you when you're
reading it should follow this
chronological order you have you know
Batman arriving in a prison and you know
arriving in Arkham Asylum fighting
alongside the Joker who's revealed to be
Dick Grayson that's how you know you're
starting quarter of the elves the way
you know you're starting nine of the
owls is it picks up when Batman's in his
in his a in Wayne Manor and all the
lights are turned dim down and he's
looking at like a building that's the
start of night of elo slash city of the
owls it's I don't really look at it as
like City the owls per se I just look at
it as a night of the owls in all honesty
when it comes to something like that
because of how its set up my suggestion
is to read the trades because this it's
organized by way of it being a trait
it's organized that way um it gets a
little hairy when you get into that
territory like like death of the family
for example the death of the family has
two trades
there's the Joker trade and the Batman
trade the Joker trade has to tie ants
that Batman trade does not and so you
know it really kind of depends on what
you want to do because you know after
going through the story but because it
has continuity things because it brings
in a bunch of Batman's continuity from
before new 52 like I'm doing the I'm
gonna try to do the whole kit and
kaboodle know but uh nonetheless so um I
hope it answered the question let me
know let me know if it answered your
question or not do I think that if DC
introduced a character more powerful
than Superman allah beerus what would
that be a great Superman story where
even with his overwhelming power he is
still in significant well they've done
that before I mean they had you know
beat him to death isn't the problem
isn't who Superman's fighting the
problem is what do you do with Superman
once they're done fighting and that's
the issue with this character is you
know like that's the issue with Superman
the problem with Superman isn't who he's
fighting the problem is Superman when he
ghost when he turns the lights off and
goes to bed at night
he's just so stupidly powerful that it's
difficult to make a story where you can
where you say like he's vulnerable like
he can be defeated by someone and that's
why I think Superman truth is so good
because Superman truth brings him down a
few notches it takes him down it
basically is Golden Age era power level
and it says like this is Superman now
you know Superman is he's strong and
he's powerful just not as strong and
powerful as it used to be nowhere near
that anyway and so I think it you know
it's great because it gives you stories
where you know there's a legitimate
chance that he could die you know and
that's that's what makes a story's good
you know at least for me anyway you know
the problem was I think you know it's
difficult to me the significance of
Superman is not his powers it's not you
know laser vision or I guess heat vision
super-strength SuperSpeed you know all
kind of good stuff
it's what Superman represents that I
think makes him significant the powers
that he has are just a byproduct of that
those are just a symbol of what he is
and that's just kind of you know who he
is as a person because he's just been
that way for so long you know what
Superman stands for could still be the
same thing albeit you know with him
having less power and I think that's
that's what they're trying to maintain
so um let's see
good morning Rob excited for the new
Frank Miller dark 93 yeah I'm actually
kind of interested to see what he does
with that but Frank Miller has become
progressively more unhinged as time has
gone the time has gone on so it could
just be the Frank Miller just produces
some incredibly insane story
did you read daredevil number 18 no I
haven't finished a lot his last days yet
I finished Loki's last days I finished
silver surfers last days but I haven't
read daredevil or Black Widow yet and so
I haven't heard yeah I haven't had a
chance to read err get alert like well
yet so um bye my headphones are sick
what brand
these are AKG headphones
let's see Wow what music are you
listening to you right now I am
listening to TSO live at Tomorrowland
2015 like I'm a huge like like EDM head
like I've been listening to eat him
since way back when like I remember like
in search of sunrise was the first like
trance album that I picked up and I
immediately fell in love with the sound
I was like oh my god this music is
amazing you know it was real actually
but it was upbeat at the same time and
it got me into DJing you know and it got
me into like you know making my own
mixes and stuff like that you know and
and which actually here let me let me uh
I think I could provide and provide a
link let me send this to you guys
because I used to make my own mixes back
in the day there we go I think I get
some that yeah there you go it's that
Mixcloud link um I used to make mixes
back in the day what you can even find
him there but um it was it was so fun
but uh no like I like listening to you
know EDM or listening to some kind of
music well I'm doing these commerson
coffee otherwise it just feels weird you
know it makes you feel kind of naked
does that makes any sense
and I don't about a huge fan of that are
you late no ah let's see um what's my DJ
name I don't really have one has just
robbed at the time I made that that
Mitch cloud it was it was studio 26 I
thought it sounded so cool and then like
in hindsight as I think kinda sounds
dumb and so I got rid of but it has a
whole bunch of stuff like I think some
of the more recent stuff is like the
whole electro house craze that's going
on right now but you know nonetheless
you know I was just kind of fun to mix
stuff and try different things and so on
and so forth but you know the whole
trance and it's what I prefer you know
um
like like reflect there's a song called
reflect by Mayer levy which is freaking
amazing a civil war which side are you
on Iron Man I'm always on Iron Man's
side during Civil War are you reading
Fight Club - no I'm not reading fight
club didn't even know it existed
yo Rob what anime would you be
explaining besides DBZ well DBZ will be
appearing pretty frequently on my
channel
having said that you know I also want to
get my toe into other stuff and see what
else you know people find interesting
you know if I try a bunch of different
animes and it's just not nearly as
popular as Dragonball Z then we'll stick
with Dragonball Z you know it doesn't
make any sense to do videos that people
don't care about or the majority of
people don't care about um you know I
mean I want to try to retail next week
you know kind of provide this overall
explanation you know of the Naruto
series what is the Reuters series you
know why was it made that kind of thing
and you know and if that's popular then
you know maybe getting more in depth
into the characters and things like that
um you know after that you know I just
kind of really just swinging from the
hip and seeing seen what's out there or
seeing what's interesting you know let's
see do you think you could do chemistry
explain video I need help with my
homework what are you working on stoic
geometry there's lot of that bad still
gallantry has chemistry with algebra
let's see I'm so glad I finally caught a
live stream your channel is a pleasure
and happy to be a fan thank you so much
you're 34 years old I'm 31 years old so
we're not that far away from each other
Oh from from a 34 year old okay my son
and I listen when we drive around big
fans that's awesome that's really cool
that my channel can serve is kind of
like a bonding moment for a father and
his son like that's that's really
humbling I appreciate that
yeah Pokemon is yeah I never got into
Pokemon as a kid wall-eyed okay I got
into Pokemon as a kid but like you know
I don't know maybe I will do something
about Pokemon I'm not sure but greatest
comic villain ever ooh
Doctor Doom definitely who wins Luke
Cage or Wolverine ah shame probably
let's see the weekly for the week here
weekly flow my weekly flow do I think
Black Panther was underrated not by a
long shot a lot of people know who Black
Panther is Blackman is a perfect example
of a character that can be relevant that
could be prevalent and not fight all the
time like that's that's what Black
Panther is and he's he's a solid
character but she's one of the smartest
people in the Marvel Universe and so
yeah what year did I start YouTube last
year
let's see yeah like like March no
February so my god of last year yeah so
it's only been about a year and a half
something like that a couple years it's
it's it's YouTube's a learning curve man
like let me let me tell you guys like
it's it's it's a learning curve like
like I'm just now getting to my channel
to the point where it's like okay like
here's here's how things work you know
and here's how my channel is warning
progress going forward and and so on and
I've got a video schedule set up and
everything I mean it's you know I didn't
know any of that stuff like I literally
just made have made a channel and I'll
tell people until the end of time I got
lucky you know with YouTube like I was I
was in the right place at the right time
and and I made I made there were three
things that made my youtube channel take
off the first was Scarlet Witch the
second was apocalypse and the third was
Civil War and after that like my channel
just exploded and I was literally like
like just swinging I was like oh my god
no I was flying by the seat of my pants
I had no idea what I was doing and and
that's that's the great thing about
YouTube is learning how it works and
figuring out how it works and you know
getting things set up and even now it's
a learning curve you know and I've
learned a lot from from different people
you know Ben he's taught me a whole
bunch stuff about how YouTube works and
different things like that and you know
as well the videos got scaled down from
20 minutes because one sort of making
youtube videos for a living I can't make
a living off youtube videos that are 20
minutes
you know it's just not practical you
know when I was working at UK was
different you know it was entirely
possible you know because it was a hobby
you know I already had a second source
of income you know YouTube's my sole
source of income you know and so you
know I I had to make videos that would
allow me to make a living off youtube
you know and and that's why the videos
got scaled down you know 2 to 20 minutes
but after your I guess guys got scaled
down from 20 minutes but after a while
you know I kind of miss going more in
depth and then the problem that I ran
into was you know skewing the videos
down to 10 minutes
didn't leave a lot of room to explain
you know what the videos are you know
where I guess like what the importance
of the videos are how is significant
they are and also explain a story and so
I just kind of like you know cast aside
the idea of like you know constrictions
basically I kind of cast aside the idea
of like these like videos need to be a
certain length you know and if simply
the videos will be as long as they need
to be you know and just went from there
you know and then DC explain came along
and it was okay you know let's let's do
DC explained you know and DC explained
was really a thought
experiment more than anything else you
know what people be receptive if I
started making videos based on DC Comics
and they were and so I said okay comics
explained role DC back in you know the
problem is I was still learning about DC
and so I may have kind of jumped the gun
but I I you know I was still reading DC
still learning about DC still trying to
you know understand
I like how people say that like I missed
a 20 minute vids like Robbie I don't
want you to be able to make youtube
videos for a living I'd rather you just
go back to work at your other job you
know that you hated and do video do
YouTube videos like part-time you know
it's no not gonna happen but um no like
it was you know it was it was like okay
you know trying to trying to get things
working I was trying to trying to
understand you know trying to relate
DC's continuity from somebody who had
been from Marvel for so long you know
and once I got that sorted out it was
like okay let's bring DC and then it was
an experiment and it's just it's nuts
you know trying to trying to figure out
how DC works you know that's why
Vinnie's channel blew me out of the
water so fast you know because because
if you guys tracked it the bidding and I
started around the same time but then
you know my channel just kind of started
to like stagnate and it sort of the
falters I was trying to figure things
out and then Benny was just shooting
straight up because he knew how YouTube
works when he got into it and and he was
like here's what I do here's how I'll
succeed you know plan initiated done and
done and he blew up and that's awesome
you know it's I think it's I think it's
one of the really cool things because I
think a lot of people have a tendency
you know to believe in bidding if I have
noticed this you know and different live
streams or in comment sections or things
like that you know I think there's a
tendency to believe that there's some
kind of like competition or animosity
and while there is some measure of
competition you know I guess really not
much of a competition anymore but when
there was competition you know it was it
was friendly you know it was it was you
know it was it was kind of like a witty
banter back and forth between me and
Benny you know which one can come out on
top at this point he's doubled my
channel so yeah there's no competition
anymore but you know but right now you
know it's it's there's no there's no
drill you know like the rotation I mean
I've never understood why people you
know viewed it that way but but no I
mean it's it's you know
YouTube has been an incredible
experience I will say that and it's
funny you know going from a job where I
felt so sure of myself on how things
worked on knowing how things worked and
and understanding how things work -
going into YouTube and starting from
square one it's insane like it's nuts
and so it's it's fun it's I've really
enjoyed you know and that's the nature
of things you I mean if this channel
fizzles out and you know it all dries up
and gets to the point where just people
don't care about videos anymore cuz I've
changed stuff so much and they're just
like we don't care about your channel
anymore when people stop watching and
people stop subscribing you know and it
all just kind of goes away I didn't go
back to working at my job
you know when and walk away saying that
I had an incredible experience but if it
continues to grow and it continues to
expand and I do this for the next ten
years that's awesome - so you know and
we'll see what happens you know it's
just
YouTube's crazy it's fun it's just so
difficult to you know to figure out at
times but I love gene grant classic
x-men do you think Phoenix is overdone I
love you yeah the problem with the
Phoenix force you know is it was a lot
of fans really kind of felt like they
should have left the Phoenix dead the
Phoenix em song didn't need to happen
that when Jean Grey died at the end of
the Dark Phoenix or I guess when it was
revealed that the Phoenix had copied
Jean Grey at the end of the Dark Phoenix
saga you know because the stories thirty
years old at this point was known I mean
if no spoilers but you know I think that
at the end of uh you know at the end of
endgame and I'm sorry not not in Game
somebody kept putting in game and you
know at the end of the Dark Phoenix saga
when the Phoenix force kind of took off
you know a lot of fans think you just
should have been left there and that
should have been it with the Phoenix
nothing more you know and and it should
have been done but you know it really
kind of depends but the Phoenix you know
was introduced as an elemental part of
the universe you know and and and it's a
necessary aspect of the Marvel Universe
represents you know all life all psychic
energy all that stuff you know and so
it's make sense we would see it in too
you know going into secret wars and that
was a problem you know that I guess that
was a thing I'm Tom Brevoort you know
the main editor guy and uh at Marvel or
I guess one of the bigwigs of Marvel had
stated that you know events like eight
of Ultron
and the vision versus Avengers vs. x-men
all that stuff all those stories had
been initiated you know with Secret Wars
in mind and so Avengers vs. x-men was a
way to basically bring the Phoenix force
back so that the Phoenix force would be
there when Secret Wars happened
makes sense let's see will you ever do
doc vodoo explained now probably not
what about Amadeus Cho being the new
Hulk it makes perfect sense um if any of
you guys read Planet Hulk I don't know
how many of you guys are reading Planet
Hulk right now but one planet hook first
launched they basically had like a
bachelor or a backup feature that
explained how Planet Hulk came into
existence and it came into existence
because of Amadeus Cho you know because
aim had launched some kind of terrorist
attack against the world and they were
launching missiles all over the place
and Amadeus Cho had been experimenting
with gamma radiation and he was like
well rather than letting the missiles
kill everybody we're going to like stuff
this missile full of gamma radiation you
know while it's flying towards the city
and then when it explodes just gonna
turn everybody in a hoax and that's how
that's what planet-- whole came from and
you know once once the story finishes
you know we'll get into the explanation
about Planet Hulk fit or I guess wants
to see once the Secret Wars event finish
it's only five parts I think and so you
know it makes perfect sense that out of
that they would make Amadeus Cho the new
Hulk you know and and plus I think I'm a
days Cho was gonna is gonna start
appearing in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you know we've got Helen Cho
and and you know of course it makes
sense we would see her son at some point
online it's so I don't know if you have
a reference having a son in the movie
age of ultron or not I don't remember if
somebody knows supposed to you know post
up in the chat let me know if she have a
reference having a son or not
um let's see have I would Avengers
forever yeah I read Avengers I wasn't
too impressed it was different than when
I thought it was gonna be to be honest I
wasn't really sure I liked it I kind of
felt like I was you know well talked
about arrow season for here in a second
I thought I was kind of like duped you
know I thought it was gonna be an
explanation of like what the world was
like with you know dude we're not with
doing with Ultron taking over the world
like we saw when Captain America was
thrown like five hundred years into the
future I thought we were gonna see that
but we didn't we just kind of saw
Avengers from all across the history of
the event of
was kinda knew what he pulled together
to fight doombots or something like that
I don't remember it was kind of dumb um
she did not okay okay uh let's see I
have heard that MCU is trying to replace
oh we were gonna sort my Green Arrow um
a green arrow season 4 it looks amazing
like it looks incredible you know and
and yeah I would featuring perfect
number five we talked about that a
little bit ago um green arrow season 4
like I'm really excited for green arrow
season 4 you know as far as I know
they're basically getting rid of like
all Oliver Queen's stuff and they're
saying like green arrow going forward
like he's not called the arrow he's not
called all of the ladies called green
arrow and then I'm really diggin like
I'm really looking forward to that I'm
having said that you know I wouldn't
mind seeing some more characters
introduced and will cross over as things
like that Arsenal's gone you know and as
far as I know like like his younger
sister will be taking on the mantle of
speedy which is cool you know because
speedy was a sidekick in the comics you
know and so I'm kind of looking forward
to that but um you know it's I mean our
son wants to you know but but it's it'll
be cool to see what happens um having
said that you know I'd actually kind of
like to see what they would do if they
were experimenting with the idea of of
the flash Barry Allen going back in time
and I guess going into the multiverse
you know and bringing back some
characters like I'd love to see you like
Jay Garrick appear and then see how Jake
Jay Garrick interacts with Green Arrow
like that would be that'd be pretty cool
you know I'm also hoping they take away
you know some of the the dark room
nature of this show and provide a more
comedic edge you know because Oliver
Queen in the comics was funny
you know the show right now feels more
like a Batman show that anything and
that's not to say it's bad the show it's
really good I mean I really love it you
know it's just I wish it would stop
feeling more like Batman and start
feeling more like Green Arrow but you
know let's see what's up you know either
way I'm not skipping over it like I'm
gonna be watching it um let's see what
does Superman's non American citizenship
carry over the Superman's non American
citizenship carry over to the news
stories I have no idea what do I think
of the east of West so far I think it's
a cool concept you know the four
horsemen wake up and death woke up
before everybody else there's a cool
concept you know I mean I like the idea
it's hitman I mean he never really
writes bad stories you know I'm right
now I've got the year one book a year
one trade which is Hugh
which makes sense because it's hitman so
like you know reading DC reading stories
and stuff like that it's no um let's see
have I read Dragonball multiverse not
yet
let's see Rob do you would you do x-men
executioner song there's no reason to do
that now I mean unless unless like
strife becomes you know listen unless
they introduce strife on Fox
there's some reason I do executioner
song and and I mean it's a cool story
but I thought would confuse people you
know and so yeah yeah it'd be weird will
they ever visit Marvel vs. DC oh I hope
they do I wish they would like I wish
would give us an animated film I don't
they don't need to be like a full-length
feature film just an animated film of
model versus DC um let's see if anything
explained trolls explain now the
banhammer explains trolls the banhammer
deals with trolls let's see Rob if there
was no Fantastic Four film controversy
do you think Fantastic Four would have
would be even relevant in Marvel at this
point not now
probably not only Marvel cancelled
before the movie even came out so no
okay I mean if you're talking about if
the movie took off and became really
popular and if it if it cornered like a
90 something percent on Rotten Tomatoes
yeah like you would see a sudden shift
in the story and you would see or you
would see like you know you would see
read be like we should reform a team it
like in one of the comics should people
be like the Fantastic Four is coming
back yes you know or something Marvel
would have liked Marvel would have done
something they would have gone into
overdrive and just like just sudden like
churned out a fantastic four book all of
a sudden you know let's see
any opinions on Justice League gods and
monsters I have already yet but I really
really want to like I really want to get
into that let's see a sell shot all over
the executioner so I saw that I didn't
think it was that bad it wasn't I mean
the executioner song was it wasn't the
worst ever but you know we're Secret
Wars part 6 the comics not out yet
I mean it's I told I'll tell you guys in
the first part of the video that like
we're going over the comics as they come
out and so if I haven't gone over yet
it's because it's not out yet so um
let's see
I loved your recent Walking Dead video
keep making that yeah it was it was
pretty fun to make um see the thing
here's a kicker though like like one
thing you guys will notice is if when we
get to Hershel's farm and the prison
things are wildly different like they're
so different between the show and the
comics it's not even funny
let's see
Rob what's your what's my favorite
Batman comic um hmm I'm not sure
probably The Killing Joke I really enjoy
that I'm gonna enjoyed how dark that
story was let's see Rob Rob I froze I
didn't freeze I had my head down and I
was looking at my looking at mine they
like I'm frozen do you do I like fear
The Walking Dead oh yeah if you're the
lucky guys really good it's starting out
the same way that Walking Dead did and
people are like oh my god this show
starting out so slow well I mean how do
you how else are you gonna explain the
characters how is he gonna get people a
foundation for it you know um let's see
what's your uh let's see Rob what do you
have so many questions coming in um Rob
what are you currently reading from DC
I'm reading I'm reading it rather just
Justice League dark side Wars Green
Lantern the Wasel army the main Green
Lantern series Batman and Superman
let's see favorite secret war stallion
old man Logan do I want JK Simmons to
appear as J jonah Jameson in the
spider-man movie yes definitely
I stopped watching The Walking Dead
after the governor shot several the shot
dead several people
who could've who could have shot back
should I watch it again you should be
watching The Walking Dead right now yes
you should definitely be watching The
Walking Dead yeah there was a community
you're gonna miss some awesome stuff of
you yeah because my goal is to get up to
the community by the time the Walking
Dead TV show comes back on you know
that's that's my goal
Superman Superman vs iron man with
Hulkbuster armor we're not doing vs
battles guys we're not doing we did a
whole bunch of those last time we're not
doing that this time let's see what are
you gonna post a definitive Superman
when I finish it and I'm working on it
when when I can but time is scarce
there's just not enough hours of the day
so well I do Darkseid words when it's
completed yes see Darkseid where's is
another example like like we could
literally just say like here's a story
of like we could literally cover the
first six issues of Justice League and
jump in a Darkseid Wars that's it I mean
it's so easy to do that that's one of
the cool things about DC story that's
one thing that I will give DC when they
can keep things could find like
character or team based story arcs and
they don't do massive crossover events
like that's really easy to do like that
that's something that I think is pretty
cool as you can get with the origin and
then jump to any story any event you
know for the most part they don't
usually tie into each other and they
don't usually you know you don't usually
build on top of one another um you know
like Batman is different because he's
such a high seller it makes sense to do
that but uh let's see what's your
favorite Green Lantern um how's Jordan
definitely your thoughts on ant-man last
days it was a good send-off
I mean it's goes up to the incursians in
the world coming to an end I still feel
like Marvel should have done last day's
first and then gone into Secret Wars but
you know it's all good do I follow a
rough script or making videos or just
general points you come up with most
from the top of your head we'll see you
do old videos and ones that were like
great big huge neon the great big huge
long ones that you know that make it
impossible to make youtube videos for a
living
those were off the top of my head you
know and the ones that are our current
like the ones I do now those are scripts
those are those are all scripts yeah
what brain of coffee are you drinking
today I'm bringing dreaming the water
brand of coffee where Secret Wars part
six already answered that question
I need to keep asking it I'm just gonna
kick you out Rob thoughts on no
registration act in the MCU well I don't
know I mean I don't know about that I
guess I will have to watch your video um
let's see any opinions on middle Gear
Solid series be like it or hate oh I
love Metal Gear Solid I don't play Metal
Gear Solid 5 yet but I'd love no Gear
Solid this is great series of games I
started Metal Gear Solid 1 from the play
well not know yourself yeah Metal Gear
Solid on the PlayStation that was really
fun um do you have a way of keeping
track of what you read yeah the issue
numbers I mean I read all the books over
the course of a week so did I see
Straight Outta Compton
no thoughts on Gjallarhorn destiny
screwed it up sucks now
you guys won I was like a diamond you
know it was later and it was awesome and
now is valueless because everybody has
it um have you played legendary a Marvel
deck-building and now I haven't played
that I haven't played in really any
tabletop Marvel games why is Thor
unworthy we don't know am I reading
outcasts or witch's thoughts
I haven't read either and if you guys
caught the podcast last time I uploaded
him I was looking up witches when I was
talking to Tiffany and Faust and I was
like this is some weird stuff and so I
was like I'm not reading that the Ranger
issues it depends
for crossover events trades for events
that follow the single character issues
I mean peanuts my mornings usually
consists of three packets of peanuts
some water and then for lunch I'll have
a steak and then for dinner I'll have
like salmon or someone but it's weird
because I have more energy and I'm more
productive when I don't eat and so once
I get all my recording and everything
done then I'll you lunch or something
like that how long we've been doing this
okay we got about two more minutes and I
gotta bounce out of here um who I'll
just do you play Al Simmons if they
remake a swan movie um honestly I didn't
think that I didn't think that um
Michael's right was that bad I thought
it was pretty good
what's the difference between trades and
issues trades collect multiple issues
take for example mm-hmm take for example
Avengers vs. x-men no Civil War Marvel
Civil War is a really good example
that's spanned over the course of a year
spanned a single year and it basically
you know covered a multitude of
different events it covered a multitude
of different comic book titles all kinds
of different stuff what I would say is
an instance like that trades are better
because what trades will do as it'll say
here's everything up until the point
where like here's here's the the road to
Civil War discovered which covers the
Illuminati a covers spider-man and
covers Ironman and I think Captain
America and then it'll say okay here's
everything from the time that the
Registration Act was implemented and the
heroes like the you know Captain America
formed his own team up until some period
and it'll collect a whole bunch of
different issues like trades are better
if you have big crossover events issues
are better if you just have a single
event taking place over the course of
one title you know like like Captain
America
the death of Captain America is a really
good example death of Captain America
takes up with it takes place in three
volumes it's 15 issues I think and it
takes place in Captain America vol 5 I
guess five six seven whatever you want
to call it but with that you could
simply described by all the issues but
if you were to say yes I'm like Civil
War it'd be trades because there's so
much involved and it just takes away the
hassle of trying to organize all the
issues for yourself so angry Tiffany
versus one where Hulk angry Tiffany um
Rob who do you think should play Captain
America Captain Marvel in the MCU ah
Ronda Rousey definitely antara Magnus
explained hello Magnus i'ts antara
Magnus is pretty fun in these pretty
hilarious you guys to check them out if
you haven't already um is there
somewhere can we coming online yeah
Marvel unlimited the other entire back
catalogue the only problem is as far as
I know they're not current you have to
wait six months I'm gonna check it out
for a while since I've been so focused
on DC but um let's see and I am still
weirded out when the mainstream view
Carol Danvers was Captain Marvel instead
of Miss Marvel oh not really I'm not
because she took the name shop tomorrow
let's see well your Marvel's been dead
since 1984 I don't know anybody who's
who would who say like Marvel is a
definitive Captain Marvel he's been dead
for 30 years let's say you are not a
Ronda Rousey fan what on
what is your favorite Marvel story ever
who probably sits like a toss-up between
Civil War and house of him random
questions rent a question any thought on
intermittent fasting I'm not enough of a
health expert to answer that question to
be honest that's the question you should
ask the hodgetwins let's see
best best live action movie ever
ooh probably The Dark Knight Returns or
the Dark Knight rather why are you
awesome I don't think I'm that awesome
now let's see what kind of food it's
good to go with comic reading anything
let's see let's talk about Batman POW
I'm not going to talk about that man
folk favorite black superhero new that's
a good question hmm
my favorite black superhero probably
black panther I mean I was kind of
debating on like Luke Cage for a minute
there mostly probably black panther
let's see puck from Alpha Flight and
puck was a goofy character do I sniff my
comics no I don't should they make what
we're hoping to movie yes definitely um
let's see
Rob great question your thoughts on
Kevin Feige and MCU changes I'm actually
not that upset about it um you know
honestly this is one of those things we
have to wait to see how it plays out it
could prove to be disastrous or to prove
to be really good it really kind of
depends I mean you see here's the kicker
it's not as though Kevin Feige has no
idea what's going on he has a lot of
knowledge about Marvel Comics and it
could just be that you know they just
wasn't really a need for as many
creators to be contributors you know as
was as they existed up to this point and
really kind of dependents you know in my
mind I think he knows enough about about
Marvel Comics to be able to create an
effective cinematic universe but again
you know what it's kind of have to see
so um let's see what is the best model
story ever waste war DC questions people
are asking ok Lobo movie I'm down with
that I am down with a Lobo movie I would
love to see I would love to see like
it's as long as it's like pre new 52
Lobo that won't be funny flashpoint
paradox your favorite animated film
thoughts on it yes sir this my favorite
animated film um
it was cool it was almost in line with
the comic almost toe-to-toe with the
comic and that I think was an important
aspect that's that I think is what made
it so interesting it's because you
didn't have to watch it and then be like
I wonder how close to the comic this is
you were like this is almost exactly
like the comic and so that I think it's
one of the things that made it so
awesome um let's see
Lobo Lobo bro that's a tough phrase I
watched the back read Lantern vids of
viewers and I'm interested in I'll
scroll up do have the other colors and
their titles or they just have they just
crossed over Green Lanterns know there's
I mean no they don't have idea to know
the UM the red lanterns are the only
Lantern core that have their own title
their own comic book publication
everybody else just shows up in other
stores the indigo lanterns the star
sapphires the I guess the orange lantern
you know all those they just show up in
Green Lantern titles or or red lantern
titles but they don't have their own
let's see favorite okay can doomsday
beat Superman crime not by a long shot
not a chance thoughts on Space Jam best
movie ever any Aquaman videos coming
soon
uh maybe I'm not sure Green Lantern war
of lights well I play the guitar he does
all the time people just like put stuff
in there and for something the chat
they're just like they're just like
they're you're leaving because I don't
respond to your questions do you do you
not and see how many questions are
coming through here like are you like do
you not notice that
pose a question and I'll try to answer
it that's just you know there's 330
people in this chat room right now most
of what you're asking questions that's a
lot of questions coming in at one time
like a lot I don't know if you noticed
that but you know this a lot I like a
people who people who like that like
like doesn't rob understand how
important I am I doesn't rob knows like
my question needs to be answered
um let's see what surprises will be in
Civil War honestly I don't think there's
gonna be any I mean there's there's
people expect Captain America to die
I guess the surprise would be that he
doesn't know when people are expecting
Bucky Barnes or Falcon one of the two to
become him become Captain America after
it's done let's see I don't know I mean
I don't think there's gonna be any
surprises to be quite honest let's see
what is the best Marvel story ever
mmm-hmm for me my favorite Marvel story
of all time is the five part story of
the century but for people just depends
let's say Road
Rovio please well you wrote at some
point it depends I mean we'll see what's
up
you know um I tried my hand at storm
people just didn't really seem to care
and so I was like okay well people don't
really care about storm then I guess
we'll see what's up but let's see
thoughts on incredible Hercules um I was
very big fan of the ER of the Hercules
stories I mean I know they're they're
like a huge like a lot of fans or a lot
of people who really enjoy the Hercules
stories
I don't really dig them too much like I
I was kinda like it's all right but I
don't think it was all that great how
did I meet comic story and I found his
channel on YouTube and then I hit a
cinema message um let's see what do you
think about Howard the Duck
he's funny kind of
we're not really do I like injustice I
haven't read that much of it to be
honest you should go on comic book men
with Kevin Smith I wish I could be a
comic book man with Kevin Smith I would
love that like like I would love to be
on comic book men I thought it'd be
pretty fun
let's see Thomas Wayne Batman is epic
pretty good retelling of the calm or oh
yeah yeah yeah Batman Batman is man
Thomas Wayne Batman was pretty awesome
he was it was much darker than Bruce
Wayne you know but I mean it was it was
still pretty cool and you loved the
storm video it was a douche move they
killed her in Secret Wars I mean I don't
think so they killed a lot of heroes a
seegar but you know they brought her
back as Stormborn and so that's kind of
a cool thing which you might do a video
on the time that Thor that let's storm
lift lifted Thor's hammer I think I
might like I think I'm gonna experiment
with that you know see how we said two
people are like characters lifting the
tour's hammer like storm lifts Thor's
hammer and so on and so forth but let's
see thoughts on Red Hood and Arsenal
third time's a charm yes that's true
um Red Hood and Arsenal's actually not
that bad um Vinny actually suggested
that I read it I think like a month ago
when we were doing an episode of the
weekly pool and he was like you should
really like you should really be reading
for it a hood in our salon and so I went
out and got it I had it as my pole list
and I was actually really surprised it
was it was pretty solid like it was
really really good and so I was like
well that's that's cool so I went ahead
and stuck with it but but yeah like it's
not terrible at all it's pretty pretty
solid um let's see um since you are
doing independent comics can you explain
the tick um maybe I'm not really I'm not
really that interested in the tick I
mean keep in mind guys like I post
videos on topics that I enjoy you know
what would be the point in having a
YouTube channel if I didn't like what I
was uploading if I didn't like what I
was talking about um let's see Batman
the Animated Series explained
hmm I mean I don't make any sense um
your Vinny's comics torreón do I like
Marvel and DC better well I used to be a
huge Marvel fanboy like it like oh I'll
admit it like I was a Marvel fan boy
back in the day but um once I got into
the new 52 you know Vinny and Vinny and
Sal we're like you need to renew it did
you renew who did you you know it's it's
one of those things you know because
they were like have you read new 52 yet
I was like no I mean I've read all
Batman stuff and I just didn't like it
and I didn't couldn't really get into it
and it was like yeah you know and they
were like read new 52 and see what you
think and I picked up new 52 and I loved
it and so um you know I I was like
that's cool so so I'm a fan of DC now
you know and then stir I'm a fan of both
you know Marvel and DC and now getting
into any comics too and so that's that's
one of the weird things people seem to
have the idea that you can't be both a
Marvel and a DC fan you have to be one
of the other and to me that's that's
dumb like that's that is genuinely a
stupid idea like there are really good
stories in both like very rarely will I
say that an idea is stupid
but that's a stupid idea because there
are both really really good Marvel and
DC stories and it doesn't make any sense
to limit yourself you know I mean that
that's kind of goofy um best fighting
game ever Tekken 3
let's see Rob just want to start reading
Batman do they ever do they start over
at issue one every new year or we're
actually gonna explain that like I'm
like in my video about that death of the
family like I'm gonna go through and and
be like here's the chronolog of the
chronology of Batman in new 52 here
because what they do like if you want to
read his stories chronologically you
start with Batman's origin and then you
go with zero year which is covered over
issues 21 through 27 and then 29 to 33 I
think and then you cover and then you go
into court of the owls 9 of the Owls
death of the family
end game like that's the that's that's
how it goes up to this point so let's
see
the mystery of life explained uh equals
42 your thought about the daredevil
series it's pretty solid I mean I've
really enjoyed that irritable series
it's it seems like the mo the most like
the darkest other things so far but it's
Netflix you know and it makes perfect
sense but um I mean it's a good break
away you know it's a great it's a good
break away to see something so dark and
sinister because it doesn't feel like
it's part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but it is so that's what makes
it so cool anyway guys what we're gonna
bring we're gonna wrap this one up um I
need to work on the script for death of
the family and hopefully I'll be able to
get the video uploaded tonight
and yeah so so I'm gonna bounce off here
and I will catch you guys later peace